[Music]  miss James are you okay she's okay  Nashville delivered a shocking episode  Thursday night leaving us with a massive  cliffhanger I have two daughters who  need me I should kill him right things  got intense after rayna's stalker carl  snuck into the highway 65 offices and  managed to hold the superstar hostage  please let me go in you don't want to do  this calm down the police are gonna be  here any second thankfully Carl let  Rayna go but little did we know the  worst was yet to come  next week we'll see Raina's family deal  with the aftermath of the car crash but  will the country star survive let us  know your thoughts over on twitter at ET  now  [Music]  you